I do not think large campaigns will ever
be the same there were some absolute
rock stars on the Obama campaign
cheuvreux sparse and Macon Phillips and
Chris Hughes and what one thing that was
very interesting about the Obama
campaign was those people who are really
running the campaign people like David
ploughin and David Axelrod they
empowered these young entrepreneurs on
the campaign to run wild with technology
and to really test the boundaries of
what it could do and you know I'll give
one example of something that at the
time I don't know if people quite
understood how significant it would be
but it turned out to be significant when
the campaign decided to announce its
vice presidential pick of Vice President
Biden by text message and people could
send in their cell phone numbers and get
the alert by text message one of the
things that was amazing about that was
because so many people uh subscribe to
that because so many people wanted the
text message alert we suddenly now are
able to capture the cell phone numbers
of huge numbers of Americans which
enabled us then to have ongoing
communications with them I think that a
lot of what the Obama campaign pioneered
in terms of its in terms of its use of
technology is just going to have to
become a standard part of every national
campaign by both parties from now on and
I think that a lot of it will devolve to
to congressional and gubernatorial races
because some of what we saw I might have
this number wrong but I think that Joe
row spars had a 190 person staff one of
the things that we know about technology
is that it becomes increasingly
commoditized and increasingly
inexpensive so things that may have cost
the Obama campaign millions of dollars
some entrepreneur is out there figuring
out how to do it for hundreds of
thousands of dollars and how to sell it
so i have a feeling every candidate for
governor ever
candidate for the Senate and for the
house is saying hey how can I get some
of that Obama campaign tech mojo